SHE CAN BUST MY CHOPS.
I THINK I THINK EVERYBODY THINKS
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT,
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
>> Kimberly: SAD NEWS FOR US
HERE AT THE FIVE AND THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
WE ARE MOURNING THE LOSS OF ONE
OF OUR CREW MEMBERS.
BRIAN WAS A VITAL PART OF THE
FOX NEWS TEAM, WORKING AT THE
CHANNEL FOR EIGHT YEARS AND ON
THEIR SHOW FOR THE MAJORITY OF
HIS TENURE.
ON HIS FACE.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE KNOWN A NICER
MAN.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A WIFE, HIS
13-YEAR-OLD SON, AND A
16-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER.
THEY ARE IN OUR THOUGHTS AND IN
OUR PRAYERS.
HE WAS LOVED BY EVERYONE AND HE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE FAMILY
AND CHILDREN.
I LOST MY MOTHER WHEN I WAS TEN,
AND PEOPLE CAME TOGETHER TO MAKE
DONATIONS TO HELP OUR FAMILY.
MY BROTHER AND I.
I KNOW THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL IS
DOING THAT FOR BRYAN AND HIS
FAMILY.